the vake is not going out and debating
prominent left-wing politicians the vake
is going out you want to get back to our
Hamas story you want to get back to the
real nature of Journalism V is going out
and he's attacking the most notable and
prominent opposition leaders of all in
the United States namely the left-wing
media that language they live like
Vermin do you believe that that is as
your uh Republican colleague Chris Chris
has said neo-Nazi rhetoric this is a
classic mainstream media move pick some
individual phrase of Donald Trump focus
on literally that word without actually
interrogating the substance of what's at
issue the word was middle of a cultural
war in this country you it's actually
describing a series of behaviors you
have antifa and other related groups
that have been burning down cities for
the last 3 years in this country would
you describe wildly violating the rule
of law we have an invasion on our
Southern border we have millions of
people crossing our Southern border
let's talk about the substance of why we
have to recognize that we're not in
ordinary times the vocabulary of the
verb in or not is not what's important
well I haven't used that language so you
can look at my my track record on the
campaign Trail I talk about the issues
we all talk about them differently but
what I'm not going to do is play some
game of focusing on some word that
somebody else said without ignoring
entirely the substance of what we're
actually talking about a border crisis
of historic proportion economic
stagnation we haven't seen in 50 years
national identity crisis and a loss of
national pride in the Next Generation
that's potentially existential for this
country let's talk about our dependence
on China today we're actually talking
about xiin ping picking on Donald
Trump's word vermin to talk about that
status quo you know what's Vermin what's
running around San Francisco on a given
day before Gavin Nome cleaned it up on a
dime to roll out the red carpet for xan
Ping if he could do that for xan Ping he
could have done it on an ordinary day
this is a good strategy this is what we
want to see we want to see our
candidates own the libs look at mle down
in
Argentina Javier Malay who is an
economist you know he he's a
professor but Javier mle is also a TV
personality Javier mle is also a guy
with a silly haircut a guy who dances up
on stage and what does he do he gives
these interviews where he just
belligerently attacks the left and
people gobble it up that's what we want
to see and I don't think that's
necessarily wrong or Bas the libs run
the show they run every institution
they've run them into the ground they
obviously despise us they express their
contempt for us at every turn and so
yeah we want to see some conservatives
give it right back to
him and what's the most effective way to
do that you could do it by debating the
governor of California it'll probably be
a pretty good
debate but the way you're you're most
likely going to get that that
that minute clip that goes viral is in
one of these exchanges online so I think
V is very sharp he's a very strong
candidate especially for having
virtually zero name recognition before
he entered the race the question now is
can he close the gap I I don't really
think there are enough CNN hits in the
world for that alone to be what closes
the Gap but it could serve him pretty
well in the race and especially if Trump
does end up being the nominee it could
position him well for a cabinet position
or or something else or if Trump is out
of the race he might even have a shot at
the at the title right now go to jus.com
I've got a Christmas gift idea that is
sure to make you the hero of the Season
we all know that the holidays get a
little hectic the shopping the cooking
the never ending list of things to do
well fear not because I've discovered a
gift that is not just thoughtful it's
downright transformative that is the
gift of genell skincare from now until
Christmas J's most popular package has a
special discount just for our listeners
at Jan cell.com NES treat yourself and
your loved ones to the absolute best
skincare in the world those troubling
forehead wrinkles Fine Lines skin
redness and yes even a sagging jawline
will disappear right before you rise
with J cell's most popular collection JL
promises immediate effects you'll see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
or your money back Jus cell made
Christmas come early this year they sent
down a ton of products for our office
and everyone looks way hotter now than
they did before Simply the Best out
there go check out Jus cell you deserve
to look and feel your best this season
go to Jus cell.com noes to get this
incredible Christmas discount every
order today is instantly upgraded to
free express shipping Jus cell.com
canw today meanwhile Trump says we got
to end all this Trump uh tweets out or
he doesn't tweet it out he TR he truths
it out he says great polls just released
best ever Harvard Harris Trump 67% the
sanctimonious 9% bird brain 8 is that
Haley sorry I got I I've been a little
behind on my trump nicknames this cycle
bird brain is okay 8% ramaswami 5%
Christie dead in the water a total
loser interesting ramas Swami and chrisy
don't even chrisy who who Trump doesn't
seem to like very much they don't get
nicknames though though Trump does call
Christie a total loser dead in the water
Trump UPS 7 10% on crooked Joe Biden RNC
must save money on lowest ever ratings
debates use it against the Democrats to
stop the steal if not revamp the RNC now
that last line is the key here because R
McDaniel who runs the Republican
National Committee only has a job today
because Donald Trump is willing to allow
her to keep that
post virtually every other candidate's
calling for her to step down and major
GOP figures and major conservative
movement figures are calling for her to
step down Trump so far has said well she
can keep her job
maybe but if she doesn't end these
debates maybe we got to revamp the whole
thing and let let's say you hate Donald
Trump as you know I don't hate Donald
Trump I rather like the man but let's
say you just hate the guy or let's say
you don't hate the guy but you just
don't want him to be the nominee again
or however you
feel can you really disagree with him on
this point that the debates serve no
other purpose than to waste time and
money resources that could be spent
fighting the Democrats can you really
disagree with that
point you might say well the voters have
a right to hear the candidates
debate yeah maybe the voters don't seem
to care because Trump's refusal to show
up has not hurt him in the polls it's if
anything his polls have gone
up well sure but it's it's disrespectful
to the voters yeah again the voters
don't seem to feel that disrespect they
don't seem to care at all
well I just think we ought to have more
debates
why because that's what we have done in
the past yeah in the past we haven't had
primaries like this this is a totally
different primary because For the first
time in a 100 years you have a candidate
who was the president running for a
non-consecutive second term so it's
totally different you can't say well
that's what we did in
2008 so what's the point you might hate
him you might hate Donald Trump for
being right about this point but I don't
think that anyone seriously can deny
that he is right here there's no if the
debates were going to change the
momentum of the race wouldn't they have
done that in the first three
debates but the momentum of the race has
not changed at all in the slightest look
back at the RCP Real Clear Politics
polling average so not even just one
poll or two polls but the average of all
the polls waited in a pretty serious way
going back all the way to the very start
of this campaign what was it 15 16
months
ago nothing has changed at all candidate
goes up a little blip goes down a little
blip that's a bet that's
it so what's the
point and if they don't cut this out I
mean I'm not going to go so far as to
call for the RNC chairman to step down
but if you're Ron and McDaniel right now
you've got to take this very seriously I
do not blame the RNC chairman for any
disappointments that may have occurred
in recent election Cycles I think I
think it's cheap and easy to blame the
head of the RNC I don't think the head
of the RNC matters all that much I think
the candidates matter I think the timing
matters I think the way that the
elections are conducted whether it's
hackable electronic voting machines or
paper ballots I think that matters I
don't really think whoever sits as the
chairman of the RNC does all that
much but if you're Ron McDaniel and
you're only prominent Defender right now
is saying hey lady shape up or you're
out you probably got to take that pretty
seriously man what a great clip that was
now hey hey hey come on Jack come on man
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel see you next time